[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing trolloni
dumbledore and the prisoner of azkaban
this theory that was brought to my
attention in the comment section
suggests that sibyl trolloni a quartz
divination professor
actually predicted dumbledore's death as
early as the third book
before we get started let's just give a
round of applause to trelawney
throughout the story
she is subject to ridicule from all
manners of respected witches and wizards
divination is effectively laughed at and
her predictions are looked down upon
but in the end trelloni was of course
right in her prediction
each and every time even if sometimes
the predictions were a little vague
and open-ended under considerable
scrutiny she continued on
and performed her duties one thing worth
mentioning
however is that a large portion of the
stigma directed at trelawny
comes from the reputation that
divination bears as a whole
divination though very real was just not
particularly well received amongst the
wizarding population
divination in essence is the art of
predicting the future
there are various ways to achieve this
and methods include but are not limited
to
tea leaves fire omens crystal balls
palmistry
cartomancy astrology and dream
interpretations
however despite its proven legitimacy
divination is trashed by the likes of
mcgonagall and hermione
mcgonagall once went as far as to
describe it as one of the most
imprecise branches of magic even
dumbledore had his qualms with
divination
despite recognizing it as a legitimate
field of magic
but what's interesting about that is
that trelloni actually unknowingly
predicted dumbledore's death
and said it straight to his face in
chapter 11 of the prisoner of azkaban
dumbledore invites trolloni to join
his christmas dinner in the great hall
to this trelawney refuses
declaring i dare not headmaster if i
join the table
we shall be thirteen nothing could be
more unlucky
never forget that when 13 dine together
the first to rise will be the first to
die
trelloni thought that by joining the
group making it 13
that she would inevitably end up killing
someone the first to rise
rather than taking that risk she chose
to stand however what truly didn't know
was that peter pettigrew aka scabbers
was at the table
meaning that 13 people were already
dining shortly after
dumbledore is the first person to rise
and he is the next to die
being killed by snape atop the astronomy
tower effectively
trelloni told dumbledore that he was
going to die just
neither of them knew it this rule of 13
continues throughout the series
and is actually proven in a couple of
other circumstances
the next is in chapter 5 of the order of
the phoenix at grimald place
where sirius black is the first to rise
from the table
sirius started to rise from his chair
molly you're not the only person at this
table who cares about harry
said lupin sharply sirius sit down mrs
weasley's lower lip was trembling
sirius sank slowly back into his chair
his face white
and of course sirius was the next to die
the next time this happens is in the
deathly hallows
when after the battle of the seven
potters everyone arrives at the burrow
and sits down
tragically madaimudi died in the battle
that had just occurred
and to this lupin gets up and offers to
look for moody's body
once again there were 13 people sitting
down on this occasion
and though four of them eventually die
it's likely that lupin was the first of
the four to die
what do you guys think of this 13 theory
let me know in the comments section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time it does
not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live you